Running bravely, bravely away goes the
state of New Jersey as they file a
panicked a panicked brief, a letter
brief in the US Court appeals for the
Third Circuit trying desperately to save
their bans on AR-15s and magazines. It
is not going to work. I suspect it's
going to be a big win, but New Jersey is
freaking out. We're going to go over
what they just submitted in court just
now this morning when we come right
back.
Hey folks, I'm Mark Smith, host of the
four box of don proud American gun
owner, constitutional attorney, member
of the United States Supreme Court Barn
and proud to say the top voice of THE
SECOND AMENDMENT IN AMERICA. Thank you.
2025 and 2026 Gundy's awards. All right,
folks. This is a big deal. The state of
New Jersey is freaking out over the fact
that they're about to get spanked by the
United States Court of Appeals for the
Third Circuit based in Philadelphia
overseeing the states of New Jersey,
Delaware, and Pennsylvania.
The state of New Jersey just wrote a
frantic letter in my view talking about
why the third circuit should ignore the
quote unquote outlier decision. We'll
get to that in a moment. the outlier
decision in Benson versus the United
States out of that DC Court of Appeals.
As you may recall, the Third Circuit
right now is presiding over and getting
ready to issue opinions in two related
cases. Cheeseman and the Association of
New Jersey Rifle and Pistols
Associations. These are two related
cases. One on AR-15s, one on AR-15s and
magazines. They have been consolidated
together. They were argued together a
few months ago. The opinions are being
written as we speak. I'm sure there will
be a majority opinion and likely a few
dissents out there. Well, that's what
you expect. They got a few liberals on
the court in New Jersey. Obviously, with
that said, the state of New Jersey is
panicking and just filed a letter brief
that is very much weak T. But the fact
they filed this and the fact that they
said what they said is clear. They are
very worried that their ban on AR-15s,
semi-automatic rifles, and magazines
that hold more than 10 rounds is going
to go bye-bye
into the trash bin of history. And by
the way, when that happens, that could
give rise to a very big decision on the
shoulders of the attorney general of New
Jersey whether or not to roll the dice
and seek sir to the Supreme Court or
simply take their loss and ball and go
home where AR-15 semi-automatic rifles
and magazines hold more than 10 rounds
will be perfectly legal in New Jersey.
Because if they just let that loss
stand, which I suspect is what will
happen. I mean, I think they're going to
lose this issues. I think the third
circuit is going to say that AR-15
semi-automatic rifles are protected arms
under the Second Amendment cannot be
banned. And I think they're going to say
the same for magazines that hold more
than 10 rounds.
And then the state of New Jersey will
face a very difficult choice.
Do they seek sir to the US Supreme
Court, have it be granted, and then have
the Supreme Court destroy
those laws for the nation?
And that Jennifer Dan Davenport, that's
her name, I believe. Jennifer Davenport,
the attorney general of New Jersey. Her
name will go down as the Davenport
decision.
That is the president that wiped out all
these gun control laws in America at the
Supreme Court, or will Jennifer
Davenport, as the attorney general of
New Jersey, having suffered this big
loss, simply take her ball and go home
and say, "We will accept the loss and
not go further."
It's going to be a very difficult choice
she's going to be facing, I suspect,
very, very soon. So, with that said,
she's trying to head it off at the pass
and stop the big loss. I don't think
it's going to work. And this letter is
turning out persuasive. So, let's turn
to what New Jersey just did, trying to
shut off, head off at the pass, the
destruction of their AR-15 and magazine
bans of that state in the third circuit.
To begin with, this is what they had to
say. Trying to say, "Look, don't look.
Don't look. Oh my god, this Benson case
out of the DC Court of Appeals, you must
ignore it. Finally, the way they wrote
this letter, it actually
self-contradicted. You'll see right
here. First of all, let's see what they
write and then we'll break it down. This
court should reject the nonbinding
outlier ruling in Benson versus United
States, DC Court of Appeals, March 2026.
In Benson, a 2:1 majority of the DC
Court of Appeals held the large capacity
magazine restrictions violate the Second
Amendment. This decision not only
remains subject to onbunk review but
conflicts with every federal court to
consider assault weapons and large
capacity magazine laws. And then he has
lists a whole bunch of them. And then
goes on to say indeed the Benson
decision conflicts with a DC circuit
decision considering the very same DC
restriction. Siden Hansen versus DC. Oh
boy.
Inherent contradiction. Did you see what
New Jersey did? So in their opening
line, let's think about how funny this
is. Their opening line, they call the DC
Court of Appeals decision in Benson
versus the United States a nonbinding
outlier. Nonbinding. And then what do
they do? Literally in the second
sentence, they contradict themselves.
And how so? They literally say, "Well,
you should ignore that nonbinding
decision in Benson, but you should turn
around and embrace the nonbinding
decisions of all these other circuit
courts across America,
which isn't New Jersey. They're all
nonbinding. So why are you labeling the
Benson case nonbinding?"
And yet you're embracing to your bosom
these other non-binding cases. Oh, I
don't know. in the fourth circuit, in
the seventh circuit, in the second
circuit, in the first circuit, in the
Ninth Circuit, and even in the DC
circuit. You're embracing non-binding
decisions to justify your position. But
for some reason, the court should ignore
the supposed nonbinding decision out of
the highest court in DC in a case
involving none other than the United
States Department of Justice,
saying that this does indeed violate the
Second Amendment.
That's the first point. Second point is
labeling something an outlier when it
comes to the second amendment these
lower courts doesn't go anywhere. Let me
tell you why. Let's think about this for
a moment. Before 2008 and the Supreme
Court decision in Heler that held that
the second amendment protect an
individual right an individual right to
keep and bear arms. If you look at the
lower the inferior by the way inferior
is actually in article 3 of the US
constitution that says that the
constitution creates the supreme court
and that inferior courts that congress
creates.
So when you looked at all the inferior
courts
in the court system before 2008's Hiller
decision, the vast majority of them said
that the Second Amendment did not
protect an individual right. It said
they protected a collective right, which
is just made up nonsense, of course. But
if you look at the outliers, if you look
at the outliers, the outliers would be
the ones that said the Second Amendment
protects an individual right. This is
why I keep telling you that the Supreme
Court does not give a fig
about what lower courts think is a
general matter. They simply don't care.
They'll read it. They'll think about it,
but at the end of the day, they don't
care. So, the fact that the vast
majority of the blue state courts in
America before Heler said that there was
no individual right to keep him arms
meant nothing was swept away by Justice
Scalia's fantastic opinion in Heler. So
too in 2022,
the vast majority of the lower courts
addressing the question said that there
is no second amendment right to carry
guns out in public for self-defense.
Right? All these you got to sign to all
these circuit courts before 2022 before
brewin that said there's no right to
carry guns in public for self-defense
that the right to bear arms somehow
conflates and means the same as the
right to possess the right to keep that
they conflated two separate terms and of
course in Brun 2022 they took all of
that majority views of the lower courts
and swept it away so the fact that New
Jersey thinks they're going to get some
traction here by signing to a bunch of
these terrible anti-gun courts in San
Francisco, in Chicago, in DC, in Boston,
right? The Fourth Circuit with Harvey
Wilkinson
not going to persuade the Third Circuit
and it certainly is not going to
persuade the Supreme Court. That I can
tell you.
Moreover, let's address one specific
point because for those of you who write
about this and and that's great. I love
it when you guys write about these
things in your opeds and your articles
and your websites and social media. To
be very clear, they think they're
getting traction here by trying to say
that the United States Court of Appeals
for the DC Circuit in the Hansen case
dealing with that same large capacity
magazine regulation found that it was
constitutional under the Second
Amendment and contrasting that to the
Benson decision, which is the DC Court
of Appeals, which is kind of the state
version of um of the DC law. And they're
trying to say there's a conflict there,
but there really is not. And here's why.
Listen carefully. It's important. The
Benson case that was just decided in our
favor in the DC Court of Appeals was a
final judgment.
It was a final judgment that eliminated
a criminal conviction of Mr. Benson.
In contrast, and this is important, got
to get this right, folks. Very
important. In contrast and a critical
distinguishing factor or feature of the
Hansen case, which was decided by the
United States Court of Appeals for the
DC Circuit, was that the Hansen decision
was not on a final judgment. All the
Hansen decision said is that the
plaintiffs, the second amendment rights
claimants are arguing for a preliminary
injunction to enjoin the law pending the
several year outcome of the case. But
then it goes on to say, we're not
deciding this question on the marriage.
All we're saying in the Hansen case is
that the plaintiffs, the Second
Amendment rights claimants arguing for
the Second Amendment, they have not
established the super high burden they
must establish to get a preliminary
injunction in this case.
So, it's not a conflict between Hansen
and Benson because Hansen has not
decided the question of whether or not
AR-15s, magazines, whatever are uh vi
bans on them, violate the Second
Amendment. Hansen didn't decide that. It
was a preliminary injunction case. They
haven't decided that. That case has not
been resolved finally on a final
judgment. In contrast to Benson, which
is a final judgment that says that bans
on magazines and homeware, the 10 rounds
violate the second amendment.
Nevertheless, New Jersey is trying to
pretend that the Hansen case and the
Benson case are on equal footing as a
matter of legal authority, and that is
false. They don't point that out, but I
just did. But the New Jersey litter gets
even crazier. Here's what they argue
next. And then we're going to break this
down too. Check it out. The 2:1
majority's view in Benson that commonly
purchased weapons are per se protected
runs into five problems. Most
problematically under Bruin and the US
versus Raheem, it is ahistorical.
Widespread restrictions on Bowie knives
and slungshots came after their
proliferation caused grave harm.
Further, the popularity test produces
results the Supreme Court called
startling inside the heler for some
reason. inviable protection for nearly
200,000 machine guns in circulation to
say nothing of over 500,000 bump stocks.
Neither plaintiffs nor Benson resolve
this issue. But this court lacks the
luxury whatever test it adopts will
govern those cases too. Nor does Benson
majority address that the test is
circular contrary to the treatment of
other constitutional rights and
inconsistent with Supreme Court
president. It goes on to say that
compared to the six thorough circuit
decisions addressing these laws,
including this DC law, the lack of
historical analysis in Benson is
notable. A proper historical analysis
confirms that states can regulate
unusually dangerous weapons unsuitable
for and disproportionate to the
objective of individual self-defense.
Their authority does not turn on market
popularity. It's all crap. It's all
crap. Supreme Court's not going to
believe any of that. Okay? and nor will
the third circuit. I suspect to begin
with, let's be clear, the binding
Supreme Court precedent on an armsban
case, which this is, is Heler. Heler and
Breuan are the same methodology. But
Heler not only laid out the methodology
of text first, burden shifts to the
government. If the plaint text has been
implicated by modern gun control law,
burden shifts to the government to show
a historical tradition of firearms
regulation. When it comes to armsban
cases, the Supreme Court already decided
it and not only decided the methodology
to decide second amendment cases, they
also decided the historical tradition of
firearms regulation as applied to arms
bank cases in America when they decided
the Heler case.
As I explained in detail in my popular
article in the Harbor Journal of Law and
Public Policy, I point out that Heler
laid out the incoming uses and made it
very clear that when the Supreme Court
and Heler analyzed the entire history of
gun bans and arms bans in America, it
said that the only conceivable
historical tradition of firearms
regulation, the only conceivable
regulation that could conceivably
justify an arms ban is the standard in
the history of banning the carrying of
dangerous ous and unusual conjunctive
dangerous and unusual weapons.
If an arm is in common use by Americans
for lawful purposes, it cannot be
unusual. If it's not unusual, it cannot
meet the historical test of dangerous
and unusual.
And that's exactly what the Supreme
Court did in Heler. The Supreme Court
literally says for whatever the reason
that individual Americans buy handguns
for self-defense or whatever, the
reality is that Americans have chosen to
own overwhelmingly handguns for for
their legal purposes. And as a
consequence, the Second Amendment
prevents a court or government or anyone
from banning them. So yes, if an arm, a
bearable arm is so popular and
ubiquitous, which these magazines are,
the AR-15s are, the semi-automatic
rifles are, the handguns are, they
cannot be banned because they're in
common use for lawful purposes and thus
are not unusual and thus cannot be
dangerous and unusual, which is the
historical test already developed by the
US SUPREME COURT. THIS IS NOT NEW LAW.
New Jersey pretends that the binding law
on an Ironban case is brewin and Raheem.
See that? they site to Brun and Raheem
that's not the right law it's
supplemental but it's not the right
lawer is the right law and that is what
the Supreme Court will apply and that is
what Brett Kavanaaugh then a judge in
2011 applied in his descent in Heler 2
Heler versus DC beyond that New Jersey
says it's ahistorical it's all nonsense
they talk about Bowie knives well the
history of Bowie knives is there's a
restriction on carrying concealed Bowie
knives and that is only in a handful of
southern jurisdictions.
A few outlier jurisdictions do not make
a historical jurisdiction of fire arms
regulation or any kind of arms
regulation in America as a nation.
Beyond that, again, they try to label it
as a circular test, the incomuse test.
That's absurd because, as I've gone over
in detailed videos here, even if an arm
is not in common use, it cannot be
banned unless it's un unusually
dangerous. We've talked about that.
There's two things here. It's got to be
unusually dangerous and it has to be
unusual in American life. If it's not
unusual and thus it's in common or it's
common and not unusual, it cannot be
banned. There's nothing circular about
this. Remember, we the people get to
decide what arms we own, not they the
government. That's how this is all set
up.
We the people adopted the Constitution.
We the people adopted the amendments. We
the people get to decide what we read
and how we defend ourselves,
not a bunch of high fallutin cortias in
Trenton.
Beyond that, they lay out an absurd
proposition here. They say that the
proper historical analysis is that you
can regulate unusually dangerous weapons
unsuitable and disproportionate to
self-defense. But that's not the test.
The Supreme Court said the test
historically is you can only ban guns if
they're dangerous and unusual. Both.
Guess what? This letter doesn't say
that. This letter doesn't use the phrase
dangerous and unusual because you know
why? Because they can't meet it. And by
the way, the burden is on New Jersey to
show that these magazines are not in
communist. Never forget because the
dangerous and unusual test derives from
history. The incom derives from history.
It occurs during the historical analysis
in the text first burn shifting to the
government history analysis part. And
because this all occurs at the
historical level of the Heler brewin
methodology, guess what I'm about to
say? The burden is on the government to
justify through history
the arm restriction, the gun
restriction, the arm ban. here. That
means in Cheeseman and the Association
of New Jersey Rifle and Pistol
Associations cases, the burden is on the
state of New Jersey to show that these
magazines and the semi-automatic rifles
are not in common use by Americans for
lawful purposes. There is a zero zero%
chance that the anti-gunners in New
Jersey and Jennifer Danifenport can
demonstrate that these magazines are not
in common use because they are
ubiquitous. You compare the number of
these magazines with the number of like
Ford 150s, the most popular pickup truck
in America last I checked. You compare
the number of people that these
magazines with the number of swimmers,
the number of joggers, the number of
people that participate in marathons,
the number of electric vehicles,
whatever.
And the number of these magazines and
AR-15s and semi-automatic rifles just
far exceeds by orders of magnitude the
number of these other items in American
society, which everyone would consider
to be in common, used by Americans for
lawful purposes. So, New Jersey is in a
panic. The anti-gunners are in a panic.
And frankly, they should be because the
trend is our friend. And there's a lot
more work to be done, folks. Uh, but
keep the hope up. We're going to win
this thing. You wait. You'll see. All
right, folks. There you have it. Hope
you enjoyed today's episode. Make sure
you follow me on XBox Diner. Don't
forget to subscribe both YouTube and a
Rumble. I'll talk to you again real soon
here at the Forboxes Diner.
>> Orders up. Table 2A.